نرى ان من واجبنا الجهادي والديني ان نحيط
ملياري مسلم في العالم بان العدو الصهيوني
وخلال 100 يوم دمر معظم مساجد قطاع غزه
ودنس واحرق وجرف تلك التي وصلت اليها
الياته على الارض واوقف الاذان والصلاه في
حرب دينيه واضحه استكمالا لما بداته
عصابات الصهيونيه الدينيه من حرب على
المسجد الاقصى وهذا هو نذير شؤم ودمار على
هؤلاء القتله النازيين اذ لا قبل لهم
بالحرب على الله وهذا ثابت بنص التوراه
والانجيل والقران لكنها دعوه ايضا لكل
مسلم على وجه الارض ان يعي طبيعه الصراع
وخلفياته وطبيعه هذه الحكومه الصهيونيه
المجرمه سليله عصابات الهاجانا الارهابيه
وان اضعف
الايمان لمن عجز عن نصره الدماء البريئه
ان ينصر دين الله اذ هدمت صوامع وبيع
وصلوات ومساجد يذكر فيها اسم الله
كثيرا فلتقم صلوات القيام والقنوت في هذا
الشهر الحرام في كل مساجد العالم ولترفع
الدعوات لرب العالمين بنصر عباده المؤمنين
ودحر وتدمير المجرمين المعتدين ولينصرن
الله من ينصره ان الله لقوي عز